Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are introduced to the new kid on the block. We're
这些原则都适用于你。还有丰厚的奖品可以直接从丽莎本人那里赢取。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将介绍一位职场新人。我们
looking at the role of mental health and wellbeing practitioner. What is it? How can you train as it? What does it involve? I'm joined by a brand new qualified mental health wellbeing practitioner called Harriet. Hope you will find it so useful it may just lead to your future career. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now the route to becoming a qualified psychologist, whichever you prefer, may well involve different jobs, different roles, different transitions. Or, of course, we may choose to stop at any of the stages before and without progressing to qualified psychologist status. Today's guest contacted me to ask if I'd heard of this brand new kid on the block, which is called mental health and wellbeing practitioner. I hadn't, but I was very interested to learn more. So I've invited her on and we're going to learn together. So I hope you find this
正在探讨心理健康与福祉从业者（Mental Health and Wellbeing Practitioner）这一角色。它是什么？如何接受相关培训？它涉及哪些内容？今天我邀请到了一位刚获得资格的心理健康与福祉从业者哈丽特（Harriet）。希望你会觉得这非常有价值，它甚至可能引领你走向未来的职业生涯。嗨，欢迎来到《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。成为一名合格心理学家的途径，无论你偏好哪一种，都可能涉及不同的工作、不同的角色和不同的过渡阶段。当然，我们也可以选择在达到合格心理学家身份之前的任何阶段停下来。今天的嘉宾联系我，问我是否听说过这个职场新角色，叫做“心理健康与福祉从业者”。我没听说过，但我非常有兴趣了解更多。所以我邀请了她，我们将一起学习。所以我希望你觉得
so useful. I will look forward to catching you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along Harriet Barnes to the podcast. Hi, Harriet. Hello. Thank you so much for reaching out to me to help us learn more about the new role, but also the role that you are doing, which is the mental health and wellbeing practitioner. Yes, yeah, that's right. Thank you for having me. That's all right.
这非常有价值。我期待在节目后半部分与你相见。嗨，我想欢迎哈丽特·巴恩斯（Harriet Barnes）来到播客。嗨，哈丽特。你好。非常感谢你联系我，帮助我们了解更多关于这个新角色，以及你目前所从事的心理健康与福祉从业者这一工作。是的，没错。谢谢你邀请我。没关系。
I love being able to help illuminate new career options. So this sounds like a really viable job and potentially career for somebody it to be a psychology degree necessarily. So one element of the role is that it's encouraging people into a psychological profession or having the ability to provide psychologically informed interventions. So that's quite important to acknowledge that they're informed from lots of different backgrounds because they're quite keen to understandably sort of diversify the number and type of people offering psychology so a lot of people on in the role that I'm aware of do have a psychology degree but not everybody and it's certainly not a requirement when I applied at least. Great thanks for clarifying that did you do a psychology degree? I did yes yes so if. So if you want to know a tiny bit about my background, because it's everybody's backgrounds are so varied. It's not an example of a perfect what you would need, but just so you can have an understanding.
我喜欢能够帮助阐明新的职业选择。这听起来是一个非常可行的工作，甚至可能是某人的职业，不一定非要是心理学学位。所以这个角色的一个要素是鼓励人们进入心理学专业，或者有能力提供心理学知情的干预措施。因此，承认这些干预措施来自许多不同的背景是非常重要的，因为他们非常热衷于——可以理解——使提供心理学服务的人员数量和类型多样化。所以我所知道的这个角色中的许多人确实有心理学学位，但并非所有人都有，而且至少在我申请时，这肯定不是一个要求。太棒了，感谢你的澄清。你读的是心理学学位吗？是的，我读了。所以，如果你想了解一点我的背景，因为每个人的背景都非常多样化。这不是一个完美的“你需要什么”的例子，但只是为了让你有个了解。
So I did my psychology degree and then I went to work in education. So I worked as an A-level psychology teacher and a few other roles around that for 15 years and alongside that I did my teaching master's and also a master's in psychological research and then took a few other roles just for a year or two because I wanted to kind of have an experience outside of education working with asylum seekers, working at a university so so not really out of education, but a different type of education, and then applied for this role, which has training attached to it as well. So since I applied, I've completed my mental health and wellbeing practitioner training. Gosh, amazing. So you're a fully qualified teacher with years and years
我读了心理学学位，然后去教育领域工作。我做了15年的A-level心理学老师以及其他一些相关角色。在此期间，我完成了教学硕士学位和心理学研究硕士学位，然后又做了几年其他工作，因为我想在教育之外获得一些经验，比如与寻求庇护者一起工作，在大学工作——所以也不完全是脱离教育，而是不同类型的教育——然后申请了这个角色，它还附带培训。所以自从我申请以来，我已经完成了我的心理健康与福祉从业者培训。天哪，太棒了。所以你是一位拥有多年经验的
of experience. I think what I really like about psychology careers or about careers generally is that if you kind of have different careers like a series of them you don't just stop bringing the stuff from your previous career you know you're able to almost integrate and formulate whatever you're doing with the people you're working with the knowledge you bring forward you don't stop being an a-level teacher do you you know you bring that with you and that enhances your role and I think it's clear that you're not doing a-level teaching but all the skills all of the kind of engagement the brilliant way you'll have engaged your pupils over the years you know and how to stop them being rowdy I'm sure it's useful you bring that with you. Yeah, absolutely. I didn't expect, and it sort of seems silly now looking back, but at the time,
完全合格的教师。我认为我真正喜欢心理学职业或一般职业的一点是，如果你有不同的职业，就像一系列职业一样，你不会停止从你以前的职业中汲取东西。你知道，你几乎能够整合并制定你正在做的事情，利用你带来的知识与你共事的人进行互动。你不会停止成为一名A-level老师，对吧？你知道，你把这些带在身上，这增强了你的角色。我认为很明显你现在不是在做A-level教学，但所有的技能，所有你多年来吸引学生的方式，你知道，以及如何阻止他们吵闹，我相信这很有用，你把这些带在身上了。是的，绝对是。我没想到，现在回想起来似乎很傻，但在当时，
I sort of thought, this is, I almost felt like I was going into something completely brand new in the same way as I was when I first went into teaching. So, you know, first started my career, I thought, gosh, I'm really starting right from the beginning again. And in some ways, I was, absolutely. It's a new environment. It's getting used to working within different systems within the NHS, just like you would in any, you know, changing any kind of organisation and sort of more of a focus on risk because of the client group that the MHWP role works with. But actually, unexpectedly, a lot of the skills, because as much as I've taught in groups all my interventions are one-to-one and I have actually done one-to-one teaching as well in A-levels and you're absolutely
我有点觉得，这几乎让我感觉像是在进入一个全新的领域，就像我刚开始教书时一样。所以，你知道，刚开始我的职业生涯时，我想，天哪，我真的又从头开始了。在某些方面，我确实是。这是一个新的环境。这需要习惯在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）内的不同系统中工作，就像你在任何组织中改变一样，而且由于MHWP角色所服务的客户群体，对风险的关注更多。但实际上，出乎意料的是，很多技能——因为尽管我在小组中教过书，但我所有的干预都是一对一的，而且我实际上在A-level教学中也做过一对一的教学——你是绝对
right I kind of I have to be very mindful because I don't to be a fully a teacher wouldn't be appropriate in a psychological intervention but a lot of the skills like being able to pick up if somebody's saying they've got an example but maybe they haven't or if they're if they're drifting off and losing engagement how to bring them back and sort of just knowing how to communicate sort of psychological concepts to somebody in an accessible way yeah definitely a lot more of the skills than I realized were transferable and I think that was the case for a lot of people on my course with their different backgrounds whatever they were that they found a lot of the skills they developed just through life and through having any kind of career was really valuable
正确的。我必须非常小心，因为我不想成为一名完全的老师，这在心理干预中是不合适的。但很多技能，比如能够察觉某人是否在举例，但也许他们没有，或者如果他们走神了，失去了参与感，如何把他们拉回来，以及知道如何以一种易于理解的方式向某人传达心理学概念——是的，绝对，比我意识到的更多的技能是可以迁移的。我认为我课程中的许多人，无论他们的背景如何，都是这种情况，他们发现他们通过生活和任何职业所发展的许多技能都非常有价值。
yeah and of course it's making me think about the transactional analysis of how we kind of interact with each other and I don't know if that's anything you're familiar with but there's three circles sort of stacked one on top of the other and I think it's parent teacher child and it's making sure that we know at any one time which role we're in. So at the moment, if this is something you're not familiar with or our audience is not familiar with, you know, I'm doing the teaching. But it's useful in arguments when we realise sometimes me and my 10-year-old are both stuck in child. And that doesn't help an argument to kind of come to a nice amicable end. So just being able to sometimes in the moment be able to just observe where we're at.
是的，当然，这让我想到了我们如何相互作用的“交互分析”（Transactional Analysis），我不知道你是否熟悉这个，但有三个圆圈一个叠在另一个上面，我想是父母、成人、儿童，重要的是要确保我们在任何时候都知道我们处于哪个角色。所以目前，如果这是你不熟悉的东西，或者我们的听众不熟悉，你知道，我正在进行教学。但这在争论中很有用，当我们意识到有时我和我10岁的孩子都陷入了“儿童”状态。这对于让争论以一种愉快、友好的方式结束并没有帮助。所以，有时能够在当下观察到我们处于什么状态。
And I'm not a transactional analysis expert there. So if anyone's like, look, that's entirely wrong. What I know I am right about is there's three circles and we need to look at where we're at. So if anyone wants to come on and discuss that, because I've got got it all horrendously wrong please do feel free. So what happened then did you were you already working in a role and then you heard about the MHWP or you saw it advertised how did that unfold for you? Yeah so I was working in a role in teaching and also working for a charity as well part-time um and about a year after I'd finished my full-time teach a level psychology teaching role um and it was always
我不是交互分析专家。所以如果有人觉得，看，这完全错了。我知道我正确的是有三个圆圈，我们需要看看我们处于什么位置。所以如果有人想来讨论这个问题，因为我可能完全搞错了，请随时提出。那么后来发生了什么？你当时已经在工作中，然后听说了MHWP，还是你看到了广告？那是怎么展开的？是的，我当时在做教学工作，也兼职为一家慈善机构工作。在我结束全职A-level心理学教学工作大约一年后，这一直
something I'd wanted to do but decided now was the right time so just started to look um for job adverts so not too many tips in terms of finding them, but they're definitely out there just on the NHS. It was the NHS jobs track website. I came across, I'm trying to think what search terms I use, because at the time I didn't actually know the role existed. It's a very new role. I was in the second cohort, the first cohort of people recruited across the country. I haven't even been qualified a year yet so it was very new when I was looking at it in the summer of 2022 so I just used lots of different search
是我一直想做的事情，但决定现在是合适的时机，所以就开始寻找工作广告。在寻找它们方面没有太多技巧，但它们肯定在NHS上。那是NHS工作追踪网站。我偶然发现了，我在想我用了什么搜索词，因为当时我实际上不知道这个角色的存在。这是一个非常新的角色。我是全国招募的第二批，第一批人。我甚至还没获得资格一年，所以当我在2022年夏天寻找它时，它非常新，所以我只是用了许多不同的搜索
terms and I think I guess for me it was just being open-minded so it could have perhaps been an assistant psychology role I was looking at or a psychological well-being practitioner role and then when I saw this one I was just open-minded to this one possibly being one that I'd be interested in as well. Amazing I know when I was looking for roles I used to just literally sometimes search through all of the band four and five jobs within 30 miles of my house just to see if there was anything that would use my skills that I could apply for so I think yeah just getting a bit crafty with your search terms is a really good idea is it a funded role to train yes yeah so it's um when I applied for it was called a trainee mental health and well-being
词。我想对我来说，只是保持开放的心态。它可能是一个心理学助理角色，或者是一个心理健康从业者（PWP）角色，然后当我看到这个时，我只是对这个也可能是我感兴趣的角色保持开放态度。太棒了。我知道当我寻找角色时，我有时会字面上搜索我家方圆30英里内所有的Band 4和Band 5工作，只是为了看看是否有任何能利用我技能的工作可以申请。所以我认为，在搜索词上耍点小聪明是个好主意。这是一个带薪培训的角色吗？是的，是的。当我申请时，它被称为“心理健康与福祉从业者”培训生角色，
practitioner role um so it came with um a year of training that was funded by the service. And then once you were in service, you remain with it. So you train the service that you train in, the team that I trained in. Once I then had qualified, I moved from a band four to a band five and remained within that team as a permanent member of the team. So that's quite nice. I think that's quite different speaking to the nurses in the community mental health team. Once they qualify, like lots of roles, they then have to look for a job. So there's the stress of qualifying, doing all the hard work,
所以它附带了一年的培训，由服务部门资助。一旦你进入服务，你就留在那里。所以你在你培训的服务部门，我培训的团队。一旦我获得了资格，我就从Band 4转到了Band 5，并作为团队的永久成员留在了那个团队中。这很不错。我认为这与社区心理健康团队的护士们交谈时的情况非常不同。一旦他们获得资格，就像许多角色一样，他们就必须找工作。所以有获得资格的压力，做所有的苦差事，
and then on top of that, not necessarily knowing straight away where you'll work. So that's a really nice thing about this role. You do a year of funded training and working in the service at the same time. So you're building the relationship, starting to cement where the role fits within the team. And then once you're qualified, if anything, whilst it's new, because then you're qualified and your responsibilities change slightly. It's the relief of just working in service and not having to do any of the training, which is quite nice. Yeah, ideal. So it's the service that I've identified.
然后除此之外，不一定马上知道你会在哪里工作。所以这是这个角色的一个非常好的地方。你进行了一年的带薪培训，同时在服务部门工作。所以你正在建立关系，开始巩固这个角色在团队中的位置。然后一旦你获得了资格，如果有的话，虽然它是新的，因为那时你获得了资格，你的职责会略有变化。这是一种在服务部门工作而不需要进行任何培训的解脱，这很不错。是的，理想。所以这是我确定的服务部门。
There's a gap in the market for this role. We will train the person, get to know them, and then almost like a preceptorship, then you graduate and you become your band five qualified MHWP. Are there assignments and things to do along the way as well, Harriet? Yeah, so I started the training in November 2022. Yes, yes. And there are three modules in it. So it varies, but generally it's about two or three days out of your role is on training. And my training was online and I would assume that most with a university and I'd
这个角色在市场上有一个空白。我们将培训这个人，了解他们，然后就像一个入职培训一样，然后你毕业，成为你的Band 5合格MHWP。一路上还有作业和事情要做吗，哈丽特？是的，我在2022年11月开始了培训。是的，是的。里面有三个模块。所以情况各异，但通常大约有两到三天的时间不在你的角色中，而是在进行培训。我的培训是在线的，我会假设大多数大学的培训都是在线的，而且我
assume that most post would be online because our university covered a huge area geographically so I think realistically that's what most universities would also do. There were three modules. The first module had an assignment and something called an OSCE attached to it and focused on assessing people with. And this is a phrase that's used in the course because it's connected to the role and why it exists for working with people with severe mental health needs compared to IAPT or perhaps as they're called now, talking therapies, a mild to moderate mental health needs. This role is aimed more at people with what they call severe mental health needs or complex mental health needs. And so the first module is assessing.
会假设大多数岗位都是在线的，因为我们的大学在地理上覆盖了一个巨大的区域，所以我认为现实中大多数大学也会这样做。有三个模块。第一个模块有一个作业和一种叫做OSCE的东西，重点是评估患有……这是课程中使用的短语，因为它与角色及其存在的原因有关，即与患有严重心理健康需求的人一起工作，相比于IAPT，或者也许现在被称为“谈话疗法”，即轻度到中度心理健康需求。这个角色更多地针对那些患有所谓严重心理健康需求或复杂心理健康需求的人。所以第一个模块是评估。
So coming in and we learn things like the five Ps formulation, how to build a relationship with someone, a rapport, how to assess risk, how to develop that formulation. The second module is around care planning and that has an assignment and a reflective essay attached to it and that's about how to, as the module suggests, how to plan somebody's care. So how to kind of think about ensuring that all of the needs are met in the most appropriate way, enjoy the most, is looking at the interventions that we offer. And that's the same thing. It's an assignment
所以我们进来学习诸如“五个P”制定（5Ps formulation）、如何与某人建立关系、建立融洽关系、如何评估风险、如何制定该制定方案。第二个模块是关于护理计划的，它附带一个作业和一篇反思性文章，这是关于如何——正如模块所建议的——如何规划某人的护理。所以如何考虑确保以最合适的方式满足所有需求，享受最多，是审视我们提供的干预措施。这同样是一件事。这是一个作业，
and then something called an OSCE. And both of the assignments, both in module one and module three, are case studies. So you work with a particular person and then anonymously write up a case study about how you either assess them if it's module one or how you provided a psychological intervention if it was module three and OSCEs essentially and and the way role plays so they the way they did them is I know they've changed they're slightly different now but the way that mine was done is they had um they hired uh people with lived experience of mental health needs to um play the role of a service user or a patient um and then they watched us live as and recorded us as we provided um in the first one we provided
然后是一种叫做OSCE的东西。这两个作业，模块一和模块三中的两个，都是案例研究。所以你与一个特定的人一起工作，然后匿名写一份案例研究，关于你是如何评估他们的（如果是模块一），或者你是如何提供心理干预的（如果是模块三）。OSCE本质上是角色扮演。所以他们做这些的方式是——我知道他们已经改变了，现在略有不同——但我做的方式是，他们雇佣了有心理健康需求生活经验的人来扮演服务使用者或病人的角色，然后他们现场观察我们，并记录我们，当我们提供——在第一个中，我们提供了
an assessment session and in the second OSCE we provided a psychological intervention which they chose for us which was our confidence building one. I think that's changed now. I guess it all depends how you feel about OSCEs and how things work. I think they've changed it to try and make it a little less stressful in that you can now record it with someone else, another member of staff in the team as the service user or if you have a service user, you can ask them to do it so you don't have the pressure of knowing there's a third person right there in the moment live listening to you and judging you. Although that sounds really scary,
一个评估环节，在第二个OSCE中，我们提供了他们为我们选择的心理干预，这是我们的信心建立环节。我想现在已经改变了。我想这完全取决于你对OSCE的感受以及事情是如何运作的。我认为他们已经改变了它，试图让它不那么紧张，因为你现在可以和团队中的另一个人（作为服务使用者）一起录制它，或者如果你有服务使用者，你可以请他们做，这样你就没有那种知道现场有第三个人在听你、评判你的压力。虽然这听起来真的很可怕，
I found actually that they were really supportive. They're really keen for you to achieve everything that you need to and understand everything you need to but they are really keen to support you to to pass they want you to pass they're not there to make your life difficult or or sort of hide what the assessment criteria is and they're as supportive as possible so it wasn't as scary as it quite sounded amazing thank you that's so illuminating and it's also made me reflect upon my first ever assignment as a trainee clinical psychologist which was a role plays we were divided into groups of three i think one of us was doing filming one of us was doing the talking and then one of us was a patient um and then it was service users
但我发现实际上他们非常支持。他们非常热衷于让你实现你需要的一切，并理解你需要的一切，但他们非常热衷于支持你通过，他们希望你通过，他们不是为了让你的生活变得困难，或者隐藏评估标准是什么，他们尽可能地支持，所以它并不像听起来那么可怕。太棒了，谢谢，这太有启发性了。这也让我反思了我作为临床心理学培训生的第一个作业，那是角色扮演。我们被分成三人一组，我想我们中的一个人在拍摄，一个人在交谈，然后一个人是病人。然后是服务使用者
who rated what they thought about us i think there was three service users rated each of our videos and it felt mortifying you know i think anybody who's going to train the mental health role is going to need to be able to tolerate their distress at the idea there will be role plays you know and that there may well be feedback on those role plays and we just need to kind of hold notice that distress but then being able to tune into the feedback and you know in my case it was it was good you know I remember one piece of feedback from a service user said there's nothing I wouldn't talk to her about like she's really welcoming she's really compassionate like you know i was like oh well that's that's all right that's a high compliment isn't it it is and then i think
评价他们对我们的看法。我想有三个服务使用者评价了我们的每一个视频，这感觉很丢脸。你知道，我认为任何要培训心理健康角色的人都需要能够容忍他们对会有角色扮演的想法的痛苦，你知道，并且这些角色扮演可能会有反馈，我们只需要保持注意那种痛苦，但然后能够调入反馈。你知道，在我的例子中，它是好的，你知道，我记得一位服务使用者的一条反馈说：“没有什么我不会和她谈的，她真的很热情，她真的很富有同情心。”就像，你知道，我当时想，哦，好吧，那没关系，这是一个很高的赞美，不是吗？它是。然后我认为
that gives you permission then to to go on doesn't it you know actually maybe i'm maybe i'm not as bad as i thought i was you know maybe this is right. So in the podcast, I think it's often quite helpful to think about jargon busting. And often I use loads of jargon. I know what things need. And it's like the jargon we use is common sense. Always try to put it in brackets and in full so that people know what you mean. What does OSCE stand for? Do you know, Harriet?
这给了你许可，然后继续前进，不是吗？你知道，实际上也许我没有我想象的那么糟糕，你知道，也许这是对的。所以，在播客中，我认为思考“术语拆解”通常很有帮助。我经常使用大量的术语。我知道事情需要什么。就像我们使用的术语是常识一样。总是尝试把它们放在括号里并写全称，这样人们就知道你的意思。OSCE代表什么？你知道吗，哈丽特？
Yeah, well, it stands for Objective Structured Clinical Examination but you're absolutely right it was I had to look it up and we didn't we used it on the course without even questioning it really and then as I sort of what it stood for and I thought oh I don't I don't actually know so you are right it's very easy to fall into that trap of using jargon and and not realizing definitely absolutely with you with you mentioning about um feedback that was a skill that I discovered that I'd something I developed through my teaching that then was um that I then was able to apply and something that you know again sort of gosh didn't expect that that would be something I would um I'd need to do
是的，嗯，它代表“客观结构化临床检查”（Objective Structured Clinical Examination），但你是绝对正确的，我不得不查一下，我们在课程中使用它时甚至没有质疑它。然后当我……它代表什么，我想，哦，我不知道，我真的不知道。所以你是对的，很容易陷入使用术语而不自知的陷阱。绝对，绝对。你提到关于反馈，那是我发现的一种技能，我通过教学发展出来的，然后是……我能够应用它，而且你知道，再次，天哪，没想到那会是我需要做的事情。
I found because I found um feedback really valuable but it was very tempting to be quite self-critical and focus on the negatives and beat yourself up about the things that you that you couldn't change and in teach for anyone who doesn't know in teaching there's a lot of observation that goes on we're observed regularly in the classroom by management by peers and very occasionally by uh if we're really unlucky by Ofsted um so I found that something really difficult that I needed to develop and I found something that I found really useful was I would print off my or get in front of me my feedback and have it broken down at each point that was made and I found it I skipped straight to the stuff that was about areas for development.
我发现，因为我发现反馈非常有价值，但很容易变得非常自我批评，专注于负面，并因为你无法改变的事情而自责。在教学中，对于任何不知道的人，有很多观察，我们定期在课堂上被管理层、同行观察，偶尔如果真的很不幸，被Ofsted（英国教育标准局）观察。所以我发现那是我需要发展的一件非常困难的事情。我发现非常有用的事情是，我会打印出我的反馈，或者把它放在我面前，把它分解成所提出的每一点。我发现我直接跳到了关于发展领域的内容。
So I found that I had to, I really made a point of focusing on the strengths, exactly like you said, to really remind myself of those. But then with the areas for development, I found myself going quite circularly around a point maybe that either I didn't agree with or I thought well that was just unfortunate on the day or I can't change that so what I found really helpful was I'd have a I'd keep a clean copy but I'd also have a copy where I would cross out any of those that I didn't I couldn't do anything about because that really helped me then instead of focusing on oh I can't do anything about that that was my that was how unfortunate it then actually they disappeared. And then I had to admit, well, actually, yeah, that is a valid point. But then instead of just thinking, oh, why did I let that happen? I think right now, what can I do
所以我发现我必须，我真的特别注意专注于优势，就像你说的，真正提醒自己那些。但对于发展领域，我发现自己在一个点上相当循环，也许是我不同意，或者我想，嗯，那只是那天不幸，或者我无法改变它。所以我发现非常有帮助的是，我会保留一份干净的副本，但我也会有一份副本，我会划掉那些我无法做任何事情的，因为这真的帮助我，而不是专注于“哦，我无法做任何事情，那是多么不幸”，它实际上消失了。然后我不得不承认，嗯，实际上，是的，那是一个有效的点。但然后与其只是想，“哦，我为什么让那发生？”我想，现在，我能做什么
to change that? And I'd write that next to it, like, what is something I can move forward? And then I committed to putting that into place. So I found that a really useful way of managing feedback oh thank you so much for sharing that with us that's so important and you know I think in in these mental health careers it's it's for your own development it's also for client safety it's important that that we have been observed that people have had a chance to experience what it's like to be in a room with us, either virtually or actually in a room. And we need to shape, we need to grow, you know, I genuinely care about
来改变它？我会把它写在旁边，比如，什么是我可以推进的事情？然后我承诺把它付诸实践。所以我发现这是一种管理反馈的非常有用的方式。哦，非常感谢你与我们分享这一点，这太重要了。而且你知道，我认为在这些心理健康职业中，为了你自己的发展，也为了客户的安全，重要的是我们被观察过，人们有机会体验和我们在一起是什么感觉，无论是虚拟的还是实际上在一个房间里。我们需要塑造，我们需要成长，你知道，我真诚地关心
easing the distress of the clients I work with. And if there's something I can do that would make that more likely to happen, I want to know it. But you know, you absolutely sometimes, it's really difficult. And sometimes, you know, I think we look at compassion-focused therapy. Sometimes the angry part of ourselves will be in charge, and that's the part that scribbles it all out and goes, no, it's ridiculous, I don't know what you're talking about. Sometimes the sad part or the anxious part might be in control, and that's what's something different to say.
减轻我共事的客户的痛苦。如果有什么我可以做的能让这种情况更有可能发生，我想知道。但你知道，你绝对有时，这真的很困难。有时，你知道，我想我们看看“同情聚焦疗法”（Compassion-focused therapy）。有时我们愤怒的部分会负责，那是乱涂乱画并说“不，这很荒谬，我不知道你在说什么”的部分。有时悲伤的部分或焦虑的部分可能在控制中，那是说一些不同事情的部分。
Hopefully, over time, the combined compassionate self will be able to step into the fore and be a little bit more objective and you know supportive to yourself as a growing clinician but also you know I think we should be observed as as qualified clinicians as well so every day is a school day and I think we can always improve but um sometimes you know I've worked with clients who've complained about me as well. Sometimes we're just not a good fit for everybody because we can't be. And sometimes we know that we've got a really, really good clinical rapport with somebody. And sometimes we know it's just a little bit sticky, you know, and that's either. It's just something about some of us that we get together and it just doesn't just doesn't work.
希望随着时间的推移，结合的“同情自我”将能够走到前台，变得更加客观，你知道，支持你自己作为一名成长中的临床医生。但你知道，我认为我们也应该作为合格的临床医生被观察。所以每一天都是学习的一天，我认为我们总是可以改进。但……有时，你知道，我也和抱怨我的客户一起工作。有时我们只是不适合每个人，因为我们不能。有时我们知道我们和某人有非常、非常好的临床融洽关系。有时我们知道它只是有点粘滞，你知道，那要么是……我们在一起的某些东西，它就是不起作用。
It's not a fit. And sometimes you just need to think, to think well actually maybe this is best being assigned to a different clinician you know have a fresh start someone that that can kind of just I don't know have a more natural rapport with this client we're all different aren't we yeah absolutely and I think that's a really big focus when they look to recruit people into the mental health role and also why they're really keen for a wide variety. So absolutely, there are people with a psychological mental health background, but not everybody in the role. I believe in the recruitment process that a really big part of what they're looking at is understanding the importance of rapport and being able to build rapport.
它不合适。有时你只需要想，想，嗯，实际上也许这最好分配给不同的临床医生，你知道，有一个新的开始，有人能……我不知道，与这个客户有更自然的融洽关系。我们都是不同的，不是吗？是的，绝对。我认为当他们寻求招募人员进入心理健康角色时，这是一个非常大的重点，也是为什么他们非常热衷于广泛的多样性。所以绝对，有心理学心理健康背景的人，但不是角色中的每个人。我相信在招聘过程中，他们关注的一个非常大的部分是理解融洽关系的重要性，并能够建立融洽关系。
And I sometimes think that potentially people who haven't come from a mental health background might approach that in a different way. And especially for maybe people who've been in with services for a long time, that can feel quite refreshing. And like you say, that kind of that fresh start for people. So in the interview, there were the standard sort of interview questions that you might expect. But there was also a role play in that as well. So they are quite a fan of role plays when you're going through the process. But that one was a really simple one. It was, they didn't expect you to do anything because there's no expectation that you have any experience of clinical contact with people before. So it felt like they were looking for people who were comfortable to check in on risk.
我有时认为，可能没有心理健康背景的人可能会以不同的方式处理这个问题。特别是对于可能长期接受服务的人来说，这可能会感觉相当令人耳目一新。就像你说的，那种对人们的“新开始”。所以，在面试中，有你可能预期的标准面试问题。但其中也有一个角色扮演。所以他们确实非常喜欢角色扮演，当你经历这个过程时。但那一个是一个非常简单的。它是，他们不期望你做任何事情，因为没有期望你在之前有任何与人临床接触的经验。所以感觉他们是在寻找那些在检查风险方面感到舒适的人。
But the key thing was how you built a rapport with somebody, how you created that compassionate and safe space for them and that therapeutic relationship. So which absolutely in reality, when you're practicing can't always happen. But I guess they're looking to see that you're able to with the majority of people. Thank you. So are you given a placement supervisor? Or is that just a general supervisor? Are you giving a kind of someone from the training course themselves to kind of be your mentor or kind of tutor? How does it work in terms of support in in the training and in your placement yeah so the main areas of sort of support that are really helpful and also the kind of formally expected and required by the course and every week you should have clinical
但关键是你是如何与某人建立融洽关系的，你是如何为他们创造那种富有同情心和安全的空间以及那种治疗关系的。所以，这在现实中，当你实践时，并不总是能发生。但我猜他们是在看你是否能够与大多数人做到这一点。谢谢。那么你会被分配一名实习主管吗？还是那只是一个普通的主管？你会被分配一个来自培训课程本身的人来做你的导师或导师吗？在培训和实习中，支持方面是如何运作的？是的，所以主要的各种支持，非常有帮助，也是课程正式预期和要求的，每周你应该有临床
supervision and every two weeks you should have caseload supervision and your clinical supervision there's some strict requirements around them being somebody who's registered with the bibcp and is either a psychologist or qualified cbt therapist because almost all of the interventions we offer are cbt informed and then the caseload supervisor is somebody who's in the service is able to provide supervision so for me it was the same supervisor for both but I know in some teams it's a mental health practitioner within the community mental health team so someone with a nurse or OT background who's at a band six and then there is you get a mentor attached to you from the university, which is one of the members of staff. Obviously, I'm only talking about my university and my experience, who you could contact for kind of queries around the academic stuff, which was really helpful.
监督，每两周你应该有案例监督。你的临床监督有一些严格的要求，关于他们是BACP（英国心理咨询与治疗协会）注册的人，并且是心理学家或合格的CBT治疗师，因为我们提供的几乎所有干预措施都是CBT知情的。然后案例主管是服务部门中能够提供监督的人。所以对我来说，两个都是同一个主管，但我知道在一些团队中，它是社区心理健康团队中的心理健康从业者，所以是一个有护士或OT背景的Band 6。然后你有一个来自大学的导师，这是工作人员之一。显然，我只谈论我的大学和我的经验，你可以联系他们询问关于学术方面的问题，这非常有帮助。
And then because the rule was so new, I've been really lucky that I couldn't be involved in the start of peer support development. So somebody within our cohort one has started a peer support group for mental health wellbeing practitioners within the role, the chance to kind of talk about any concerns that we have or things like that. And she's asked, you know, I've been able to be involved with that as well. So you do generally find that if there's a group of people who are doing the same thing and the grassroots, they all start to organise and develop some peer support
然后因为这个规则太新了，我真的很幸运，我能参与同行支持发展的开始。所以我们第一批中的某个人已经为心理健康与福祉从业者在角色中开始了同行支持小组，有机会谈论我们有的任何担忧或类似的事情。她问，你知道，我也能参与其中。所以你确实通常会发现，如果有一群人正在做同样的事情，并且是草根，他们都开始组织和发展一些同行支持，
and that's been really, really helpful as well. So they're the main. And then really informal peer support. So the people on your course, you can message them and say, are you finding this assignment as difficult as me do you know what you're doing and it can be really normalization is so important isn't it you've got to have a safe space you absolutely have yeah absolutely and that was all of those different types of support were helpful at different points and in different ways but the the peer support
那也非常、非常有帮助。所以这些是主要的。然后是非常非正式的同行支持。所以你课程上的人，你可以给他们发信息说，“你觉得这个作业像我一样难吗？你知道你在做什么吗？”而且它可以……正常化是非常重要的，不是吗？你必须有一个安全的空间。你绝对有，是的，绝对。所有这些不同类型的支持在不同的点和以不同的方式都有帮助。但同行支持，
that validation is really helpful having somebody I'm lucky that i've got someone in a different team to me but in the same office and we'd regularly um in our wheelie chairs wheel over to each other and go do you know what's going on now i've got no clue either yeah exactly i love that is there a senior mental health and wellbeing practitioner? Because I know that senior PWPs are emerging. Yeah, absolutely. So I don't know the full details. So again, if somebody else knows, maybe they can come on and share that with you. But I believe the mental health and wellbeing practitioner role has come out of the community transformation work that's that's happening so moving the um community uh team mental health teams towards a more psychological focus or to have more more choice of psychological interventions um and it's but it uses a pwp model but unlike unlike PWPs where there is an IAPT or a talking therapy office where people go, there's a service being created that's just those people. Our role is similar, but we're placed within a service that already exists.
那种验证非常有帮助。有某人……我很幸运，我在一个与我不同的团队，但在同一个办公室，我们经常……在我们的轮椅上轮到彼此那里去说，“你知道现在发生了什么吗？我也不知道。”是的，完全正确。我喜欢那个。有高级心理健康与福祉从业者吗？因为我知道高级PWP正在出现。是的，绝对。所以我不知道全部细节。所以再次，如果其他人知道，也许他们可以来和你分享。但我相信心理健康与福祉从业者角色是从正在发生的社区转型工作中出来的，所以将社区心理健康团队转向更心理学的焦点，或者有更多心理干预的选择。而且它使用了一个PWP模型，但与PWP不同——在PWP中有一个IAPT或谈话治疗办公室，人们去那里，有一个正在创建的服务，只是那些人。我们的角色类似，但我们被安置在一个已经存在的服务中。
So rather than the service being made, I've been placed into a community mental health team as a role. And just like the PWP, there are discussions about senior mental health wellbeing practitioners that would be at band six. They're still being decided right at the top of the level. So our trust, just like any other trust in the country, don't have any plans to put any in place yet because they've not been advised by the strategic bodies above them what that would look like um but there are hopes there's some discussion that it could be that we would have some kind of supervisory capacity um and also we might be able
所以与其说是服务被制造出来，我被安置在一个社区心理健康团队中作为一个角色。就像PWP一样，有关于高级心理健康与福祉从业者的讨论，那将是Band 6。它们仍然在最高级别被决定。所以我们的信托，就像全国任何其他信托一样，还没有任何计划放置任何，因为他们还没有被上面的战略机构建议那会是什么样子。但有希望，有一些讨论，它可能是我们将有某种监督能力，
to offer have additional training um or the band sixes would have additional training to um offer um i don't know what the correct the right word is but slightly more complex like still still low level psychological intervention but um with um a little additional training as well lovely so are they just in adult mental health cmht services or are they in CAMHS, young people services, older adult services, psychosis, or, you know, it's fine if you don't know. Yeah, we're talking to, from talking to people on my course, we're absolutely everywhere. So my understanding of the role was to be mostly in community mental health teams where they hold a caseload of people who are defined by the organization's having severe mental health needs um but actually we've been placed in and that's where i am but there are people placed in lots of different places so
而且我们可能能够提供……有额外的培训，或者Band 6将有额外的培训来提供……我不知道正确的词是什么，但稍微复杂一点，比如仍然是低水平的心理干预，但有一点额外的培训。可爱。所以他们只是在成人心理健康CMHT服务中，还是在CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）、年轻人服务、老年人服务、精神病学中，或者，你知道，如果你不知道也没关系。是的，我们正在交谈，从与我课程上的人交谈来看，我们绝对无处不在。所以我对这个角色的理解是主要在社区心理健康团队中，他们持有一个被组织定义为有严重心理健康需求的人的案例负载。但实际上我们被安置在……那是我所在的地方，但有很多人被安置在许多不同的地方，所以
i believe there are people in early intervention psychosis eip in older adult services, in GP surgeries. So there's quite a lot of scope and based on the role and the interventions that we offer, it feels the fact that our interventions can be so helpful, they're wellbeing interventions. So in theory, absolutely anybody could benefit from them. So even people not accessing mental health services, if you think about the kind of things that they so we do behavioral activation which is getting people doing a little bit more when they're when they've got low mood a graded exposure kind of getting people helping people access situations that create anxiety confidence building problem solving sleep interventions guided self-help for binge eating disorder and there's seven so there's one more that I've missed but as you can so I wonder if I know I can identify
我相信有在早期干预精神病（EIP）的人，在老年人服务中，在GP诊所中。所以有相当多的空间，基于这个角色和我们提供的干预措施，感觉事实是我们的干预措施可以非常有帮助，它们是福祉干预措施。所以理论上，绝对任何人都可以从中受益。所以即使是不使用心理健康服务的人，如果你想想他们……所以我们做行为激活，这是让人们在情绪低落时多做一点事情，一种分级暴露，让人们帮助人们进入创造焦虑的情况，信心建立，问题解决，睡眠干预，针对暴食症的引导式自助。有七个，所以我错过了一个。但正如你所能……我想知道我是否能识别
that when I'm not feeling great I start to do less or lose my routine or my sleep starts to struggle so actually the fact that our there the interventions are so appropriate for everybody at lots of different levels, it doesn't surprise me that we're being fitted into lots of different services. There is a particular role that's slightly different in CAMHS that I believe is something like an educational mental health practitioner. So I think it's the same sort of thing, but actually we're, our role is specifically for adults and older adults. Thank you. And I was going to say, what does an average day look like? But I think you've really nicely guided us through that. And, you know, I know this isn't specifically kind of a progression route for people going on to being an educational psychologist or a clinical psychologist or a counselling psychologist but it makes me think that actually this would have been for me you know I'm excited I would have liked to have done this role this would have been
当我感觉不太好时，我开始做得更少，或者失去我的常规，或者我的睡眠开始挣扎。所以实际上，我们的干预措施对于处于许多不同水平的每个人都非常合适，这并不让我惊讶我们被安置在许多不同的服务中。在CAMHS中有一个稍微不同的特定角色，我相信是像“教育心理健康从业者”之类的东西。所以我认为这是同样的事情，但实际上我们是……我们的角色专门针对成人和老年人。谢谢。我本来想说，平均一天是什么样的？但我认为你已经很好地引导我们完成了。而且，你知道，我知道这不专门是人们继续成为教育心理学家或临床心理学家或咨询心理学家的晋升途径，但这让我想，实际上这对我来说会是……你知道，我很兴奋，我本来会喜欢做这个角色的，这本来会是
for me even better experience even better experience than like an assistant psychologist because you're getting hands-on experience for how to do these things you know why they matter which things are going to work better you know mingling in your theory practice links and getting you know the bums on seat experience of putting that into practice I guess the bit that you're not getting which I did get as an assistant is the supervision from a qualified psychologist so that's if someone is thinking this might make a really good you know next step then yes I believe personally it really really will but you unless you happen to be supervised by a clinical psychologist even if you were supervised by a clinical psychologist I think you're being supervised
对我来说，这比助理心理学家有更好的体验，因为你能获得如何处理这些事情的实践经验，你知道它们为什么重要，哪些方法更有效，你知道如何将理论与实践相结合，并获得亲身实践的经验。我想你没能获得的一点是，我在做助理时获得的来自合格心理学家的督导。所以，如果有人认为这可能是一个很好的下一步，那么是的，我个人认为它确实会非常好，但除非你恰好由临床心理学家督导，即使你是由临床心理学家督导，我认为你接受的督导也是
as a mental health and well-being practitioner not as an assistant psychologist and for me they are a little bit different because the job roles should be different but yeah for me it's it sounds really exciting and a really great way of skilling people up to either do this role for the foreseeable or to think about future roles yeah absolutely so so a couple of things there definitely it's you learn a lot about the really key skill the really key core fundamental skills and you do access some formal training which I know in some sometimes in some AP roles might be missing you know I, I now have a qualification that's formally recognised. Currently, we're not registered, but there is a discussion about us becoming a registered profession. And that's something to consider when you think about the role.
作为心理健康与福祉从业者，而不是作为助理心理学家，对我来说它们有一点不同，因为工作职责应该不同。但对我来说，这听起来真的很令人兴奋，也是一种让人们提升技能的好方法，无论是为了在可预见的未来从事这个角色，还是考虑未来的角色。是的，绝对是这样。所以有几点，你确实学到了很多关键的、核心的基本技能，并且你确实获得了一些正式培训，我知道在某些助理心理学（AP）职位中这可能是缺失的。我现在拥有一个正式认可的资格证书。目前我们还没有注册，但关于我们成为注册职业的讨论正在进行中。当你考虑这个角色时，这是需要考虑的事情。
There's some real benefits to it being new. I've been able to get involved with lots of things like service evaluation that I think if the role had existed for a long time I wouldn't be able to because they'd all already been done or setting up the peer support but there are so what comes with that is a lot of discussion about what is the role where does it fit having to perhaps wait to hear what the progression route is or maybe wait for the registration process which all of it will definitely will come. But you just have to be patient. And I viewed it as a positive. I could be there at the beginning to have those, maybe wherever possible, inform those decisions. Definitely. I've been really lucky that my supervisor is a qualified psychologist and is really supportive with my supervision in that she lets me take it wherever I need to take it and in terms of discussing the skills or the areas that I want to go in
作为一个新角色，它确实有一些真正的优势。我能够参与很多事情，比如服务评估，如果这个角色存在了很长时间，我想我可能无法参与，因为它们都已经完成了，或者建立同伴支持。但随之而来的是关于这个角色是什么、它适合哪里、可能不得不等待了解晋升途径是什么，或者可能等待注册过程的很多讨论，所有这些肯定都会到来。但你只需要有耐心。我把它看作是一个积极的方面。我可以在开始时就在那里，尽可能地为这些决定提供信息。当然。我非常幸运，我的督导是一位合格的心理学家，并且在督导方面非常支持我，她让我根据需要去探索，就讨论我想要发展的技能或领域而言。
so I suppose maybe that could be a question if it's something people are thinking of it could be a question in the interview that people might like to ask um and alongside that I think a question about how people see the the service see the role fitting into the service could be really helpful. Acknowledging that it is still a brand new role, I think run to about cohort five of trainees will be the next one. But there is still lots of things happening. So that can be a really good thing to acknowledge in an interview that it's a new role and you're interested to see how they're fitting it in and you could if you're feeling particularly confident ask about community transformation and where they are in terms of that if it's relevant to community adult mental health and I'm happy to give a very brief over you mentioned a day in the life I'm happy to give a very brief overview for people who might want to know about that so because of the training that we have in an average day,
所以我认为，如果人们正在考虑这个问题，这可能是一个在面试中人们可能想问的问题。与此同时，我认为询问人们如何看待这个角色在服务中的定位也会非常有帮助。承认这仍然是一个全新的角色，我想下一批学员将是第五批。但仍然有很多事情在发生。所以在面试中承认这是一个新角色，并且你有兴趣了解他们如何安排这个角色，这可能是一件非常好的事情。如果你感觉特别自信，可以询问关于社区转型以及他们在该方面处于什么阶段，如果这与成人社区心理健康相关的话。我很乐意给出一个非常简短的概述，你提到了日常生活，我很乐意为那些可能想了解的人提供一个非常简短的概述，因为我们所接受的培训，在平均的一天里，
we might be involved or in my average day, which will look different because I'm in CMHT to maybe somebody else. But we'd have a huddle where we join together and talk about our contacts and anyone we've got concerns, which is lots of skills there you can develop. There's then formulations that you can, that I attend that are really helpful to see how a multidisciplinary team works and where my interventions fit. It might be, it's not something I do so much, but it's absolutely something that could be part of the role, something called phase one, so where you assess somebody, which will look different in different services,
我们可能会参与，或者在我平均的一天里，因为我在社区心理健康团队（CMHT），所以可能和别人看起来不一样。但我们会有一个简短的会议，聚在一起讨论我们的联系人以及任何我们担心的对象，这里有很多技能你可以发展。然后我会参加一些非常有帮助的个案概念化会议，看看多学科团队是如何工作的，以及我的干预措施适合在哪里。这可能不是我做得最多的事情，但它绝对可以是这个角色的一部分，即所谓的“第一阶段”，也就是你评估某人，这在不同的服务中看起来会不同，
but for us it's an extended period of time gathering information for the five Ps formulation, so getting a really good understanding of people's experience and how they've what's happened to them and how they've arrived, where they have their protective factors and goal setting. What do they want to achieve? What do they want to work on? And that's so important. That's a question that's asked all the time in formulation. What does somebody actually want? What's their their focus? How can we help them achieve what they want? Not what we think they need, but what they actually want what's their their focus how can we help them um achieve what they want not what we think they need but what they actually want and then the main body of my role is offering those um low-level evidence-based psychologically informed interventions um which is all of it's
但对我们来说，这是一个收集“五个P”个案概念化信息的一段较长的时间，所以要真正很好地理解人们的经历，以及他们发生了什么，他们是如何到达这里的，他们的保护因素和目标设定是什么。他们想实现什么？他们想在什么方面努力？这非常重要。这是在个案概念化中一直被问到的问题。某人真正想要什么？他们的重点是什么？我们如何帮助他们实现他们想要的？不是我们认为他们需要的，而是他们真正想要的。他们的重点是什么？我们如何帮助他们实现他们想要的？不是我们认为他们需要的，而是他们真正想要的。然后我角色的主要部分是提供那些低强度的、基于证据的、心理学知情的干预措施，所有这些都是
great i really i genuinely really enjoy all of it but that's the real um that feels like the real the real work working one-to-one with people um and you and again in a smaller scale using exactly those same skills so having a smaller assessment with them that's focused on whichever intervention they might be using almost like a mini formulation working alongside them to help them um again to make shared decision making i'm not telling you i'm going to do this to you we're doing it together and then working through so all of our interventions are described as guided self-help so in theory they could be completed independently you could give someone a leaflet and they could do it but of course having that support gentle accountability a safe space to spare to share
很棒的，我真的非常享受这一切，但这感觉像是真正的工作，与人们一对一地工作。你再次在较小的范围内使用完全相同的技能，与他们进行较小的评估，专注于他们可能正在使用的任何干预措施，几乎就像一个小型的个案概念化，与他们并肩工作以帮助他们，再次做出共同决策。我不是在告诉你我要对你做什么，我们是在一起做。然后通过工作，所以我们所有的干预措施都被描述为引导式自助，理论上它们可以独立完成，你可以给某人一份传单，他们就可以完成，但当然，拥有那种支持、温和的问责制、一个安全的分享空间
is is a really important part of the of the process as well um supervision supervision and then anything my advice especially because it's a new role and for me i was so new to mental health i just tried to get involved in absolutely anything i could so if there was a meeting going on especially when i was in training because they they say just find out what's going on so if there's a meeting going on i'd join it if there was a free bit of training with a space on it I would join it knowing that I might not always be able to use it in my role but I always got something out of it and just asking people what do you do who are you how does that fit was really really useful too. I do and I'm very much getting the impression that the role of mental health, well-being practitioner and you specifically become the linchpin of the service because you have got your fingers in all the pies.
也是这个过程中非常重要的一部分。督导，督导，然后是我的任何建议，特别是因为这是一个新角色，对我来说，我对心理健康非常陌生，我只是尝试参与我能参与的绝对任何事情。所以如果有一个会议正在进行，特别是在我受训的时候，因为他们说只要找出正在发生什么，所以如果有一个会议正在进行，我会加入；如果有免费的培训且有空位，我会加入，我知道我可能并不总能在我的角色中使用它，但我总是能从中得到一些东西。而且只是问人们你做什么，你是谁，这怎么适合，也非常非常有帮助。我确实，而且我非常强烈地感觉到，心理健康与福祉从业者的角色，特别是你，成为了服务的核心，因为你参与了所有的事情。
You're in all the meetings. And it very much feels like when I was an assistant, it would be like, ask Marianne. Marianne will know. And I feel like that's what they say about you, Harriet. Like Harriet will know. She'll know how to do it. She'll know where it is is she'll know she'll know what's going on and why we're doing that and what options are and I guess you'll also know a lot about community interventions as well and something I only stumbled across yesterday was something called Andy's Man Club is that something you've heard of? Yeah so so interestingly whilst my caseload was building, I am moving from trainee to kind of qualified. I did look for a few other things I could do just to kind of help the service. And one of them was that we had a really good understanding of third sector support, but kind
你参加了所有的会议。这感觉非常像我做助理的时候，就像是“问玛丽安，玛丽安会知道的”。我觉得他们也是这样说你的，哈丽特。就像哈丽特会知道的。她会知道怎么做，她会知道它在哪里，她会知道正在发生什么，为什么我们要这样做，以及有哪些选择。我想你也会对社区干预措施了解很多，我昨天偶然发现了一件事，叫做“安迪男人俱乐部”（Andy's Man Club），这是你听说过的吗？是的，所以有趣的是，当我的病例量在增加时，我正从学员转变为合格人员。我确实寻找了一些我可以做的其他事情，只是为了帮助服务。其中之一是，我们对第三部门的支持有很好的了解，但
of really make some connections with those groups and kind of get to inform formulations. And yeah, one that we use a lot is Andy's Man Shed. It's a really, a very positive service that we use. Definitely. A third sector awareness is really, really key and actually acknowledge, and again, maybe in your interview or thinking about if the role, how you want to develop it,
真正与这些团体建立一些联系，并以此来为个案概念化提供信息。是的，我们经常使用的一个是“安迪男人小屋”（Andy's Man Shed）。这是一个我们使用的非常积极的服务。当然。对第三部门的认识非常非常关键，实际上要承认，同样，也许在你的面试中，或者在考虑这个角色时，你想如何发展它，
knowing about the, acknowledging that you need to develop it knowing about the acknowledging that you need to know about third sector stuff and work it joint working is really really helpful but yeah we regularly refer to to people in the community of the charity sector community sector as to either to supplement or maybe after discharge to support that transition back into the community, definitely. So important. I love that you've been able to give our audience tips for their interviews as well. That's so important. I know that sometimes the episodes where we're looking at career changes have been really, really popular. What's it like when we've got all this internal chatter about what will people say when I say I want to leave or will they think I'm ungrateful for, you know, leaving this career?
了解需要发展它，了解需要了解第三部门的东西，并且联合工作非常有帮助。但是的，我们经常向社区、慈善部门、社区部门的人员转介，要么作为补充，要么在出院后支持回到社区的过渡，当然。太重要了。我很高兴你也能为我们的听众提供面试技巧。这太重要了。我知道有时我们关注职业转变的剧集非常非常受欢迎。当我们内心有很多关于“如果我说我想离开，别人会怎么说”或者“他们会认为我忘恩负义吗”的喋喋不休时，那是什么感觉？
You know, I get holidays, I get Easter, I get summer off. Like, you know, what's it like when you suddenly realise actually I might want to leave this career I'm in and do something different? Oh, well, it took me absolutely ages. I am, which I wouldn't necessarily advise like I don't I love teaching I loved everything about it I loved where I worked um but it was time for me to try something different um I like to try and if I have something I like to try and improve it and teaching allowed me to do that because I taught the same thing every year I could change what I was um you know
你知道，我有假期，我有复活节，我有暑假。就像，你知道，当你突然意识到其实我可能想离开我现在的职业去做一些不同的事情时，那是什么感觉？哦，这花了我很长时间。我，我并不一定建议这样做，因为我热爱教学，我热爱关于它的一切，我热爱我工作的地方，但现在是时候尝试一些不同的东西了。我喜欢尝试，如果我有东西，我喜欢尝试改进它，教学让我能够做到这一点，因为我每年教同样的东西，我可以改变我的……你知道，
I could tweak and change things and you can do the same with the interventions you're delivering a sleep intervention you think oh that didn't quite work next time I'll do it like this so I still I still get that but I've kind of got to a point where it was really just sort of neatening things up you can always improve in every area um but I did it really slowly so I went down to three days a week and two days working at the charity and then I think I went down to three days a week and two days working at the charity. And then I think I went down to one and a half days teaching and the charity work and some of the university lecturing. And finally, I think I was on about one day when I left. So I really dragged it out because I've been there for years and knew everybody and what was really lovely is um there were two trainee teachers that myself
我可以调整和改变事情，你也可以对你提供的干预措施做同样的事情。一个睡眠干预，你觉得“哦，那不太奏效，下次我会这样做”，所以我仍然得到那种感觉，但我已经到了一个地步，它真的只是在整理事情。你总是可以在每个领域进行改进，但我做得非常慢，所以我减少到每周工作三天，两天在慈善机构工作。然后我想我减少到每周工作三天，两天在慈善机构工作。然后我想我减少到每周工作一天半教学，加上慈善工作和一些大学讲座。最后，我想我离开时大约只工作了一天。所以我真的把它拖得很长，因为我在那里待了很多年，认识每个人。真正可爱的是，有两个实习教师，我自己
and another colleague who left at the same time um had trained and had seen come up so as we were kind of reducing our hours they were taking them on and and they've they've both really blossomed they keep in touch with them in their careers and they're doing really well and working nicely as a unit so i guess if there are worries about if you if you are worrying about maybe leaving because of kind of those those pressures about what will people think or how will the team feel? Me leaving allowed somebody else to start their career in that area and have another person in the world who's got psychological knowledge and teaching knowledge, which was something that I really appreciated and has been really valuable to me. So it's been it was a real positive such an important reframe and I don't know if you watch friends but it reminds me of when Phoebe has moved out of Monica's but not told her
和另一位同时离开的同事，我们培训过并看着他们成长起来。所以当我们减少工作时间时，他们接手了，他们都成长得很好，我与他们保持联系，他们的职业生涯发展得很好，作为一个单位工作得很好。所以我想，如果担心因为那种关于“别人会怎么想”或“团队会怎么感觉”的压力而离开，我离开让别人有机会在那个领域开始他们的职业生涯，并让世界上多了一个拥有心理学知识和教学知识的人，这是我非常感激并对我非常有价值的事情。所以这是一个真正的积极因素。这是一个如此重要的重新框架，我不知道你是否看《老友记》，但这让我想起菲比搬出莫妮卡家但没有告诉她的时候，
and it feels like that's what you did there like where's Harriet oh she's moved out she's left didn't you notice she's been doing it like a bit by bit incrementally but that really made me smile as an idea like you just you did the transition in a slow gradual way and just it was just right for you um which I love before we finish have you got any advice for kind of reducing burnout in this mental health sphere that we find ourselves working in? I feel really lucky because I'm quite new to mental health, that everything feels very fresh. And as well as having a really supportive team, we have lots of different reflective things and support, you know, supportive things set up, which I access and I'm really encouraged and
感觉你就是那样做的，就像“哈丽特在哪里？哦，她搬走了，她离开了，你没注意到吗？”你是一点一点、循序渐进地做的，但这作为一个想法真的让我笑了，你只是以一种缓慢、渐进的方式完成了过渡，这正适合你，我喜欢这一点。在我们结束之前，你对减少我们所处的心理健康领域的职业倦怠有什么建议吗？我觉得自己很幸运，因为我对心理健康很陌生，一切都感觉非常新鲜。除了拥有一个非常支持我的团队外，我们还有许多不同的反思性事物和支持，你知道，设置了支持性的东西，我可以使用它们，并且我受到团队的鼓励和
to support by the team. So I guess one of my pieces of advice would be, having said I was there for 15 years and took years to gradually leave, what I would say now is if you're in a team that don't offer you those things or that support, then they're not the right team for you and that's a reflection on the team and not on you, which isn't my experience, but I can understand how it could be in others. And I guess maybe the thing that I really enjoy is is remaining curious being curious and I'm lucky because I'm right at the
支持。所以我想我的建议之一是，虽然我说我在那里待了15年，花了几年时间才逐渐离开，但我现在要说的是，如果你所在的团队不提供这些东西或那种支持，那么他们就不适合你，那是对团队的反映，而不是对你的反映，虽然这不是我的经历，但我可以理解在其他人身上可能会是怎样。我想也许我真正享受的是保持好奇心，保持好奇，我很幸运，因为我正处于
start so literally everything is new to me so so everything is interesting but just um kind of looking up being things fresh and new making time very even if it's briefly just to to listen to kind of new ideas or new perspectives and that's where I stumbled across your your podcast um that that it has little snapshots of different careers or I can remember one one of your podcasts that was really interesting that I really enjoyed um was around there was somebody talking about kind of a culture and and their religion and how that informed their experiences and their practices. And as I work with asylum seekers who are majority Muslim, that was really interesting and an area that I had a passion for. And it's really nice to see those brought together. And when you mentioned about third sector,
开始阶段，所以字面上一切对我来说都是新的，所以一切都很有趣。但只是……保持新鲜感，腾出时间，即使很短暂，去倾听新的想法或新的视角，这就是我偶然发现你的播客的地方，它有不同职业的小片段，或者我记得你的一期播客非常有趣，我非常喜欢，是关于有人谈论文化和他们的宗教，以及这如何影响他们的经历和实践。因为我与寻求庇护者一起工作，他们大多数是穆斯林，这非常有趣，也是我热衷的一个领域。看到这些结合在一起真的很好。当你提到第三部门时，
I after listening to one of your podcasts about you had somebody in talking about green spaces and nature that really highlighted to me the importance of that and how lovely that was so um i've embedded into looking for my third sector people i looked for people had a focus on you know got there were people with gardening and nature as well um so definitely anything where you can learn other people's perspectives can feel so it's like a change is as good as a rest it can feel really refreshing to hear those different ideas and perspectives um at any way you can find them Harriet you're trying to make me cry like I didn't realize I was gonna be in there as a as an anti-burnout tip but that's that's honestly so lovely you know that I've had this idea to do a podcast series like a podcast and that I've had this idea to do a podcast series like a podcast and that I've had this idea to to talk to certain experts and approach them about coming on and that it genuinely is leading
在听了你的一期关于有人谈论绿色空间和自然的播客后，这确实向我强调了它的重要性，以及它是多么可爱。所以我把它融入到寻找我的第三部门人员中，我寻找那些关注……你知道，有园艺和自然的人。所以绝对任何你能学习他人观点的地方都会感觉……就像改变和休息一样好，听到那些不同的想法和观点会让人感到非常清爽，无论你从哪里找到它们。哈丽特，你试图让我哭，我没想到我会作为一个抗职业倦怠的建议出现在那里，但这真的太可爱了。你知道，我有这个想法做一个播客系列，就像一个播客，我有这个想法去和某些专家交谈，并接触他们让他们来参加，这确实正在导致
to clinical shifts for people that I will never meet that will be benefiting because of the information that I've made available to clinicians like that's getting me a bit teary I won't lie like this is why I do what I do people are like why do you do this because it costs you money you don't make any money from it I'm like because I passionately believe in easing the distress of others but also giving great evidence-based practice for clinicians who I'll never meet who then get to go off and make people's lives better or make their own lives better or both. You know, that's why I do it. And thank you so much for saying that, because that's that's incredible.
临床上的转变，对于那些我永远不会见到的人，他们会因为我提供给临床医生的信息而受益。这让我有点想流泪，我不撒谎，这就是我做我所做的事情的原因。人们问“你为什么做这个？因为它花你的钱，你从中赚不到任何钱”，我说因为我热切地相信减轻他人的痛苦，同时也为我永远不会见到的临床医生提供伟大的循证实践，他们然后去让人们的生活变得更好，或者让自己的生活变得更好，或者两者兼而有之。你知道，这就是我做它的原因。非常感谢你这么说，因为这太不可思议了。
Thank you. You're welcome. And I think as well, I know that you offer the aspiring psychologist, the membership. And I do wonder if that would allow the same thing, because you have the weekly lectures with people with different um perspectives so some of that of course would be career development but other elements would just be oh gosh yeah I never thought about that connection you know it's amazing how many connections you can make so so yeah definitely lots of really uh lots of really helpful things connected to you thank you so much thank you so much I will just briefly mention there's books available as well if anyone wants to check those out thank you so much for for approaching me about this podcast episode for helping us learn about the mental health and well-being practitioner do you get to graduate
谢谢。不客气。而且我也认为，我知道你提供“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格。我确实想知道这是否会产生同样的效果，因为你有每周与拥有不同观点的人进行的讲座，所以其中一些当然是职业发展，但其他元素只是“哦天哪，是的，我从未想过那种联系”，你知道，你能建立的联系数量是惊人的。所以是的，绝对有很多非常有帮助的事情与你联系在一起。非常感谢，非常感谢。我会简要提到也有书籍可供选择，如果有人想查看那些。非常感谢你联系我参加这期播客，帮助我们了解心理健康与福祉从业者。你毕业时会得到
do you get another little hat and a robe thingamajig like yeah there is um there is a graduation uh service yes definitely which is very nice after all that hard work to like you say get to do that little throwing the hat and yay so does it last a year it sounds like it's kind of rolling like there's multiple starts in the in the yeah in the calendar year but the whole process lasts a year yeah so um the recruitment the start of the courses and I think it's you I think it's universal not just um our trust is November and March so now would probably be quite a good time to people will be advertising for trainees the training is a year and then after the year one year is a band four after the year of training it's um and then you go into band five into a permanent post which is very
你会得到另一顶小帽子和长袍之类的东西吗？是的，有毕业典礼，是的，绝对有，这非常好，在所有努力工作之后，像你说的，去做那个扔帽子的动作，耶。所以它持续一年吗？听起来它是滚动式的，一年中有多次开始，但整个过程持续一年。是的，所以招聘、课程开始，我想这是普遍的，不仅仅是我们信托机构，是11月和3月。所以现在可能是人们招聘学员的好时机。培训是一年，然后一年后是4级（Band 4），培训一年后，然后你进入5级（Band 5）担任永久职位，这非常
nice i love it thank you so much this honestly would have been a bit of me like this would have been amazing i think how incredible that we've got these new and diverse mental health practitioner roles for people to be able to do but also people to be able to benefit from thank you so much for speaking to us thank you ever so much for having me. You're so welcome. Oh, how lovely to have met Harriet and to be guided through the process with such expert care and attention. And yeah, I feel like it was such a great chat. And I think this would have been something that I would have really liked myself if it had been around an earlier stage of my career. What do you think? What does this sound like to you? Is this something you would be interested in exploring? I would love to know what you think. Do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook where you can let me know. You can also start a chat with me on socials about it,
好，我喜欢它，非常感谢。这真的会是我的菜，这太棒了。我认为我们拥有这些新的、多样化的心理健康从业者角色供人们从事，同时也让人们能够从中受益，这真是太不可思议了。非常感谢你与我们交谈。非常感谢你的邀请。你太客气了。哦，见到哈丽特并以如此专业的关怀和关注引导我们完成这个过程真是太好了。是的，我觉得这是一次很棒的谈话。而且我认为如果这在我职业生涯的早期阶段就存在的话，我会非常喜欢的。你觉得呢？这听起来对你来说怎么样？这是你有兴趣探索的东西吗？我很想知道你的想法。请来到Facebook上的“有抱负的心理学家”社区，在那里你可以告诉我。你也可以在社交媒体上开始与我聊天，关于它，
any of my socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. If you would like to read the stories of aspiring psychologists, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. And there's also experiences of clinical health counselling psychologists, educational psychologists in the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I just want to thank you for your time in listening to or watching this episode. I know your time is precious and you know I'm just really grateful that you trust in me to help you learn more about the field of psychology. Please do take a moment to rate and review. Please do subscribe to the channel.
我的任何社交媒体。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。如果你想阅读有抱负的心理学家的故事，请查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书。在《临床心理学家集体》一书中还有临床健康咨询心理学家、教育心理学家的经历。我只想感谢你花时间收听或观看这一集。我知道你的时间很宝贵，你知道我真的很感激你信任我，让我帮助你更多地了解心理学领域。请花一点时间评价和评论。请订阅该频道。
I will look forward to bringing you the next episode of the podcast, which will be released as an MP3 on Monday mornings at 6 a.m. And it's usually available on YouTube across the weekend before it's launched as an mp3. Thank you so much, take good care of yourselves, be kind and I'll say you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing
我期待着为你带来下一期播客，它将于周一早上6点以MP3形式发布。它通常在作为MP3发布之前的周末在YouTube上提供。非常感谢，照顾好自己，保持善良，我会说你会在成为合格人员的道路上。这是与玛丽安博士的“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者学员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》一书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有完美的途径成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做
it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
错，并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。